number one overall seed is knocked out
in the division series happened to the
Giants happened to the Dodgers happened
to the Braves tonight and it's the
second straight year that the Phillies
are moving on to the National League
Championship Series and just like did
you just tweet that I mean somebody may
have taken my phone and have done it
I've been here with you Ernie I know you
there it is right there you just been
waiting to hit the send button on that
thing for the last three innings go
official you know we throw it up here a
little early but you know I have to make
sure it went official hey it's uh MLB on
TBS yeah the closer is presented by
Genesis Ernie Johnson Curtis Jimmy and
Pedro man was that a wild night
congratulations I know you I know you
bleed that uh Philadelphia red do man
this was this was Edge ofe seed stuff
Jimmy um you know we didn't expect
anything less than that but both teams
were ready both teams were game
uh big time players made the big plays
when they needed them the most it did
get sketchy but if you're from
Philadelphia if you know anything about
the Philadelphia sports scene that's
where it's supposed to happen nothing's
easy nothing smooth it's like you
holding on to the edge of your seat
White Knuckles and then that Elation
that eruption and that building is
shaking oh my gosh we'll uh we'll break
I'm smiling I can't help I'm sorry if
I'm cheesing all night you know what it
is you know I'm just saying we'll break
it all down here just a second first let
me show you what's uh uh the the
schedule for the National League
Championship Series uh Diamondbacks and
Phillies first two games will be in
Philadelphia first game is
Monday
7:30 eastern time you heard from Nick
casos who homered twice in that game as
he spoke with Matt Wier here is Bryce
Harper with
[Music]
Matt chy
congratulations you just took out the
best team in baseball in the regular
season why was it so dominant from your
perspective it's a really good team over
there and they played such a great year
this year and I have so much respect for
them and the way they go about it um
what type of team they are one through
nine their pitching staff as well um and
we just did so good tonight I mean
coming in here playing in front of this
fan base there's nothing like it whole
field advantage is real and you know
Ranger threw really well our Bullpen
came in shut the door huge two two
swings by castios and Trey Turner and
that's why they're here that's why you
spend the money baby 11 home runs over
the series six over the last couple of
games how good do you feel about where
this offense is right now yeah we're
excited man we uh I think we're all
clicking on the same cylinder we got a
couple guys that could do it a little
bit more and you know I think we get
that going you know we're tough to beat
so um we just lined up our pitching as
well our onew Ace uh going first game
and second game Arizona's really good as
well they're hot they're young um they
got some pretty good pitching as well
and we're excited for the series and
what does it mean to have home field
here for the NLCS there's nothing like
it it's the best fan base in America um
in the world I mean it's unbelievable
coming in here it's hard to play in here
and we know that um so we're going to go
in and have some fun Monday night you
came back out to first base but got to
ask how's the elbow I'm good just hit my
Funny Bone so feels better now I imagine
yeah I'm fine congratulations thank you
appreciate
it the Phillies win at 3 to1 Bryce
Harper pointed out the Philadelphia
Bullpen which by the way in this series
14 and a third two earned runs and that
but that is not to say there weren't
some moments that got pretty hairy uh
let's go to the seventh inning of this
one and because it was quickly two outs
and then back to back to back walks and
then miss Kevin po at third how does he
not score Curtis you know it's a small
back drop uh back drop back behind home
plate in Philadelphia as you're making
the break from third base right there
you're seeing the ball bounce off at the
same time you may also not know how far
it's bouncing off is it bouncing right
to JT can I beat Craig kemell to the
plate I also don't want to make the last
out of the inning with this rally going
on so you have a lot of stuff going on
right there and his run doesn't matter
at that point in
time aunia still at the plate and check
this out the rookie Johan Roos makes the
catch I'm still nervous looking at it
even though I know he made the catch
that a Euro Step before even went up
thought that think so hey it's because
Outfield point right there I mean I
didn't get a lot of games out there but
you know that field it's not uniform out
there in second field and you're going
out there trying to make a play you have
your corner outfielder coming out there
and this point that's coming out you I
can't run into the wall but I got to
make a play right there he Stutter Steps
he's able to make the play secures it in
a big moment I've seen that ball drop
many of times not not only just guys
backing up but outfielder hitting
outfielder arms get tangled up and a
ball uh uh gets out into the corner it
happened to me end up being like a
triple and a throwing air coming in and
I score the game Ty and
run at that moment it is so loud as
close as I am to you
Ernie they can't hear you can't hear
everything sounds the same and you're
guessing yes you've played there you've
practiced going back on that ball but
when it's a moment like that that field
gets a little smaller those moments
become more precious and you talk about
a critical moment in the game
understanding if this ball drops and
they score we're going back to Atlanta
but the catch was made but it was made
the uh the rally was ended and
Philadelphia hangs on to Win It 3-1 even
even in the ninth inning things got
dicey Rob Thompson did a job managing
that Bullpen yes he did and I and I I
was talking to Jimmy earlier and I said
Jimmy I know because to me it was really
weird first of all because Kimbro did
not do a good job all year adding
hurting Runners and second of all
because it's a seventh inning and I
could understand his mindset the game he
saved where where it calls for it so he
went to his best relever his closer in
the seventh inning that did not make me
feel comfortable because I knew Kimbro
wasn't going to last too long to get to
the end of the game so but thanks to God
he has those kind of arms that he can
use he has alberado he has uh Soto he
has Hoffman which I was really surprised
he didn't use I don't know what's going
on or what happened since the last time
but I was hoping that Hopman was the kid
that took the ball when Kimbro came in
yeah as Brian save one of those two
closers for for the end of the game and
Brian Anderson pointed it out in the in
the broadcast he said they're really
working with an inverted Bullpen now the
the sixth and seventh inning guys are
going to be the eighth and Ninth had a
boy Harper take out the shirt Got a Boy
har Mario Brother overalls has that been
a rallying cry and look it's person but
you know what
we have to give kudos to to Thompson for
actually pulling the the right guys at
the right time and pushing the right
buttons I mean that's gutsy what he did
to take out both closers and have
someone with just two saved in his
career come and save that Clincher is uh
good to him you think you prepared you
think he's prepped loaded loaded locked
and loaded how about the job Ranger SW
did tonight outstanding but you know
what rer has you know kind of let listen
in real quick with the most wins in
baseball I'm so proud of everybody
there's so
everybody was in on this everybody
contributed unbelievable Cassy you're
[Applause]
[Music]
stud
stry you're
stu by the way you're all
[Music]
studs how many more we got
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
there are just certain things when you
saw that that are meaningful in a
clubhouse and to the fan it's like what
did that mean why are they doing that
but those are things that you guys do in
the course of a season things that
become ritual things that become
tradition and things that are celebrated
on a night like this they definitely are
and these are the times that you do that
you've worked hard to get to this
position you hope that you go on but
there's no guarantee that you're going
to go on so you party like it's the last
one until there's a next one and you
hope there's a next one you hope there's
one more but those things that happen in
a clubhouse on a plane during the game
that bring you together they become
rallying cries they do become tradition
no one understands it except for the
guys in that Clubhouse and as you said
even I'm I'm trying to figure out like
what are they doing and then you say it
doesn't matter this is what they do
guarantee the crowd if they win the next
series everybody in that crowd is going
to do the yeah yeah after the game yep
um one night for the Phillies going back
to the National League Championship
Series and uh here on this show uh we
make our way toward finding out who
Pedro's daddy is oh yeah we always have
some
nominees and only one game in town so
you know it has to come from somebody
wearing a red hat with a pee on it I
know I know it should be and and uh I'm
extremely happy to see all all four of
them in that in that pool right there uh
I'll wait and see what the fans are
saying about it but uh I think I made up
my mind
already I think I made up my
mind each one of them could be my daddy
easily don't let anybody know yet Pedro
couple seconds from now and we will uh
we will take a break and come back with
more on the what if I
24 no you can't do that against the
rules that's a ry's the commissioner hey
hold on you can't have four daddies in
one night it's just you can't you can't
do it
nice camera shot it was at
first